from circuit boards and electronic
components that end up in some apple
products to patio furniture and plenty
of other things a lot of the goods we
use every day are produced in china and
those factories have been getting
messages from the local government that
there's not enough electricity and a lot
of cities have had blackouts
restrictions came quite unexpected were
allowed to work during restricted hours
which was mostly at night right now
china is facing its biggest power crisis
in more than a decade which is leading
to power outages and temporary factory
closures in one of the world's largest
manufacturing hubs
if chinese factories continue having
problems getting electricity there could
be ripple effects around the world and
the main problem is coal
china is the world's biggest consumer of
the dirty fossil fuel and its dependency
on it is exposing some pain points in
the country's transition to a greener
future while threatening to delay how
quickly we'll be able to get our made in
china products
to keep manufacturing hubs running and
the lights on for citizens china needs a
lot of power and last year about 60
percent of it came from burning coal but
recently this demand has soared china
recovered from the economic impact of
the kova 19 pandemic much earlier than
other economies so as a result it has
been producing and exporting more goods
which require a lot more electricity
usage
its factories ramped up to make
components for iphones and video game
gadgets that consumers in the west
wanted while stuck at home
but china hasn't been able to source
enough coal from domestic producers
because there's been safety issues in
coal mines and anti-corruption probes
plus flooding in one of china's coal
mining provinces is also threatening the
supply
at the same time importing hasn't been
easy either they have imposed this
unofficial ban on australian coal
imports one of the
usual sources that they would go to for
coal
since late last year china has barred
coal from australia after canberra
called for an independent global inquiry
into the origins of coven 19.
so china has had to find other suppliers
in indonesia and mongolia but sourcing
has been getting more difficult because
now other parts of the world are
beginning to emerge from the pandemic
too and there's not enough coal to go
around so right now coal prices have
climbed to their highest level in a
decade and so when coal prices climb
higher it really disincentivizes power
plants in china from generating more
power even if the demand is there that's
because until very recently government
rules prevented power producers from
passing on higher costs to customers so
instead of firing up the generators
they've chosen to cut down production
all this has led to widespread power
shortages in china
it's also affected factories like this
one in the southern manufacturing hub of
guangdong we'd have to adapt ourselves
to to these restrictions
thomas bergers manages this patio
furniture factory
he says since early august he's been
receiving text messages from the local
government asking to restrict power
usage they send daily message they give
a specific period where you are allowed
to work in
and yeah then we will have to adjust our
production schedule
so his factory had to occasionally close
during peak hours and open between 11 pm
and 8 a.m according to the government's
instructions we didn't have restrictions
like
you cannot totally work anymore so that
we were still
be able to continue our production
but several other companies haven't been
so lucky including several apple
suppliers
concraft an electronic component
supplier said it had to temporarily
suspend production for about five days s
on precision which supplies mechanical
parts and uni micron technology which
makes printed circuit boards also
stopped production for about five days
apple didn't respond to a request for
comment
meanwhile more than 10 trip related
companies in china's eastern city of
kunshan said they temporarily closed
their facilities for about five days at
the end of september
bruges says he continues to get messages
from the government about whether the
factory can use power normally
for now production is back on schedule
but he says he's prepared to shut down
at a moment's notice the chance is
always there i have learned that in
china you have to
cooperate with a certain flexibility the
rules are set it is what it is that's
what we have to do
and that cooperation will be important
because beijing has set itself a big
climate goal
to make that happen china has been using
a target electricity use must grow at a
lower rate than gdp but in the first
half of this year electricity use rose
more than gdp and hitting beijing's
target could become more difficult as
winter approaches and demands for
heating increase these power outages
really show how reliant china is still
on coal despite their push to transition
into greener energy sources and curb
carbon emissions and so going into the
future they're going to be forced to
balance some goals
to balance these goals beijing hinted in
mid-october that it would need to
rethink its path and pacing for reaching
its climate target
china's leadership has said electricity
occurs for high-energy users such as
steel and cement will continue to stay
but to address immediate needs the
country has now stepped up its coal
supplies while allowing prices of
coal-fired power to increase
with all the unpredictability factory
owners like berger's are starting to
think about how to ensure their own
stable power source we are also
considering about the sustainable energy
can we plant solar panels on our roof is
there an alternative way of getting
energy and
besides a diesel generator but if in the
short run the power crisis in china
continues the impact could hit closer to
home that could weigh on manufacturing
activity and economic growth in china
which subsequently could affect the rest
of the world whether people are going to
be able to get their products on time or
will even face higher costs for them